in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
I'm with British Tila mana well-known
yoga expert not only in Germany but
worldwide I guess thanks for inviting me
into your Center today
what is it about yoga what people love I
think people love yoga because it really
integrates body mind and soul and on one
hand people are looking for something
that keeps them fit but at the same time
they need to recharge the batteries they
need to they need some relaxation and
yoga breeches that and I think that's
why it really works in this day and age
so it's not only in relaxation technique
it's a training for the whole body
what does yoga do to the body yoga helps
you to connect to yourself and to be
inspired again and then really go out
with more energy and feel alive and it's
modern yoga different to the yoga forms
which developed say 5000 years ago yes
yoga today for the most part is very
different originally yoga was designed
to to meditate longer that they
developed the postures the yoga asanas
so people could meditate for a longer
time with ease and this in this day and
age we have many different reasons to
practice yoga and so that has changed
yoga even though it has its roots in
India is now more global so there
influences from all over the world and
if you call your Center spirit yoga but
this focuses on the spirit as well or
more on the body a spirit yoga does
focus on the on the spirit as well it's
it's well-rounded and integrated
approach yeah it keeps you fit it keeps
your body and shape but at the same time
and make sure that your it puts your
head straight and you also connect to
what's really essential in life and why
is keeping you with your body in shape I
mean is it just the stretching or is it
muscle training or what what happens in
the body what you do in yoga it's all of
it it's not just stretch
your flexibility what a lot of people
think and that's why there are lots of
people who say oh I can't do yoga
because I'm not limber enough that
actually would be a good reason to try
yoga because it gives you more physical
freedom and not just physical mentally -
I think but it's that's not just the
only thing it also strengthens your body
at centers you so besides cardiovascular
training that's the one thing yoga can
do but everything else like strengths
and flexibility Yoga can give you really
very well there's so many different
forms of yoga what do you think about
this that yoga is diversifying so much I
think it's good because Yoga is meant to
evolve and this helps it and I think the
methods that have substance will stay
alive and the other ones will fall away
and time we can't get stuck in the
tradition all the time because then the
whole thing becomes stale so I think to
maintain the creativity it's also trial
and error you change might be good but
how long is it yoga and when does it
just start to be physical exercise well
I think we should ask ourselves a
question what is really essential and
what's just you know impressive and so
we're looking for the essential and
we're also looking for an approach
that's still integrative that speaks to
the body to the mind and the soul and
and I think to me that what yoga really
is that there's a deeper connection but
isn't that out of pressure when you take
a look at those modern forms of yoga
like techno yoga rare to get better and
better and better and perform even
better so this is not the essential of
yoga is it no that's definitely not the
essential of yoga and you could hurt
yourself if you practice that way and I
do see that there is a danger when
people come into the yoga room with a
very worldly mindset of competitive edge
and then you have a class that
furthers that even more that that's
dangerous and then you could hurt
yourself but so we should be aware of
that that yoga still has the health
aspect and is taught in a mindful way
okay now I'm motivated enough to start
yoga but I won't buy a DVD or a book I
want to join cause at a Yoga Center but
when I take a look at the hosts ladies
here behind us they're doing it really
great I would be embarrassed to join of
course together with them well you don't
have to do what they do and it's not
about pressing yourself into a form
which you're not you know nobody is
happier or healthier because he could do
a free headstand so it's really about
your individual approach to it and a
good teacher will help you with that and
so don't worry that you have to do
something which it's difficult for you
you will go step by step and you will
feel more ease more freedom and more
strength and that's what it's really
about Yoga is functional it's not about
putting yourself into some fixed form
okay so it's more about the inner me and
what what I feel inside me and what can
I I can do to my own body then what
other people think about me totally yeah
and I think especially now living more
on our mobile phones and in the digital
world we lose that connection to
ourselves so it's really essential to
get into your body again to fear
yourself and it's not something that's
self-indulgent it's really helpful to be
connected again and then to go out from
that place into the world again yeah
that's the point because if I practice
yoga on a regular basis in the center
how can I take this what I learn here
into the real world well that's really
the the essence of what we're doing here
when you have challenges in the yoga
room you can observe how you react and
often what happens is people become a
victim or they grind their teeth and
they go and I'm gonna just push through
so those are usually
two ways to do it and you learn in time
to find a third way a more mindful way
to steer through calm and centered and
this approach you can carry from the
yoga mat out into the real world and
that's really beneficial so yoga really
is the real thing thanks so much for
inviting me into your studio today thank
you